et
on va parler de la guerre en ukraine
bonjour sans mike gomes bonjour d'amiens
en plein milieu de ce conflit pour la
première fois des mercenaires présumés
sont accusés de crimes de guerre oui des
mercenaires qui sont dans le viseur de
la justice en ukraine et c'est le
guardian qui rapporte cette information
ce matin premières accusations de crimes
de guerre contre des mercenaires dans
conflit ukrainien titre le quotidien
britannique
il cite ici l'identité de deux
combattants présumés du sulfureux groupe
wagner de biélorussie il sait il y à
aussi à un mercenaire russe certains
auraient combattu en syrie nous dit le
journal au total ce sont huit hommes
dont cinq soldats russes qui sont ici
accusé par le parquet de kiev de meurtre
et de torture de civils non loin de la
capitale dans le village de mots teasing
c'est là qu'ont aussi été retrouvés dans
des fosses communes c'est non loin de
butch a également une enquête sur la
base donc de photos des images de
vidéosurveillance et à chaque fois de
centaines de témoignages donc ont permis
d'identifier de confirmer l'identité de
ces individus des hommes qui sont
toujours actuellement sur le terrain
nous disent ce quotidien qui sont
probablement dont le dombass on ne sait
pas s'ils seront
capturés ou non en tous les cas ils sont
activement recherchés voilà avec leurs
noms et leurs photos qui sont publiés
donc dans les journaux on s'intéresse
maintenant l'émotion internationale
après le carnage dans cette école
primaire du texte oui on va regarder en
les unes de la presse européenne ce
matin d une qui sont assez insoutenable
damian la république a regardé ce
trombinoscope
avec ces visages d'enfants innocents ils
ont entre 7 et 10 ans tombé sous les
balles de ce forcené 18 ans dans leur
salle de classe et ce titre un de la
république à la tuerie des enfants 19 au
total ans et deux enseignants ont été
lâchement assassinés
même idée encore une fois la une d'el
país avec ce titre ici qui montre toute
l'impuissance aux états unis la tuerie
qui met en évidence l'incapacité
politique face au lobby des armes et
puis bien sûr la presse américaine
qui titre à nouveau en une sur 7 sur ce
massacre des visages qui s'affichent
donc en une du new york times visage
d'une perte je cite incommensurable pour
cette ville du val d' au texas une ville
un mot dit-on d'éleveurs une ville
mexicano-américaine très uni où les vies
je cite sont liés par des générations
d'amitié et de mariage et puis le deuil
de cette petite bourgade de dust2 16
mille habitants elle est symbolisée
aussi damien part c'est une ce matin une
noire ce jeudi celle du une valve de
leader news en malgré cette nouvelle
fusillade le bi américain des armes à
feu la haine avait décidé de maintenir
sa convention annuelle et elle se passe
justement au texas oui elle se passe à
houston c'est vendredi en trois jours
seulement après cette fusillade est donc
à seulement quatre heures du lieu de ce
drame le houston chronicle ici rapporte
que de nombreuses protestations vont
avoir lieu vous le voyez un sur cette
photo où l'un des protagonistes de cette
convention des têtes d'affiché bien
c'est l'ancien président donald trump on
attend aussi la prise de parole dans
lors de cette convention du gouverneur
greg abbott et du sénateur du texas tech
cruz
illustration du cynisme ici de cette
convention cette caricature de matt
walker pour politico on voit être causés
et donald trump 1 qui arrive sur la
pointe des pieds pour ne pas salir leurs
chaussures avec le sang des victimes et
pour finir on prend des nouvelles de
boris johnson un premier ministre
britannique est à la fête en tout cas en
une de toute la presse du royaume uni
oui à boris johnson à la à la fête aux
apéro festif en tout la eu toute la
presse britannique relais les photos qui
font scandale celle du rapport final
accablant de l' enquête administrative
qui a été menée par la haute
fonctionnaire sous grèce sur la série de
treize soirées au total qui ont été
organisée à downing street pendant les
confinements en 2020 et 2021 un rapport
qui a été repoussé pendant des mois et
puis finalement révélé hier au public
alors les photos de boris johnson vous
le voyez ici il tient une canette à la
main et ça c'était pendant lors de sa
fête surprise pour son anniversaire lors
de ses 56 en juin 2020 plus précisément
et vous vous regardez dans ce jeu de mot
du sun deux parties sauveur la partie
est donc terminée le tabloïd qui met le
premier ministre au défi d'aider ses
lecteurs à traverser la crise actuelle
la crise d'augmentation du coût de la
vie un autre journal cette fois le
northon ico se veut particulièrement
virulent il reprend cette phrase d'un
député de l'opposition il y a du sang
sur vos mains de privilégier référence
bien sûr ici aux gens à tous ces gens
qui sont morts pendant la pandémie et le
confinement
le quotidien régional qui livre ici bien
tous les détails de cette soirée
quelqu'un qui a vomi lors des fêtes du
vin rouge renversé sur une photocopieuse
des genres qui en viennent aux mains et
puis le journal conservateur times celui
bien ne retient pas ses coups non plus
et parle d'un rapport qui énonce une
litanie de cynisme d'illégalité qui fait
honte à l'administration boris johnson
la question la question ici posée par ce
rapport c'est de savoir dans quelle
mesure boris johnson est affaibli par
les nouvelles révélations
la conclusion ici c'est qu'il n'est pas
mort tellement de blessés on va regarder
pour finir un dessin de peter brook dans
le times il est temps nous dit-on ici de
tourner la page il est temps de tourner
la page des beuveries des employés ivre
à des déchets sur les bureaux du 10 dans
une suite et donc de ce rapport regret
que l'on voit dans la poubelle merci
beaucoup 120go baisse